was that no I think
ha
hi everybody i justjust to welcome again
florian ending and also just to sort of
a reflect a little bit just started your
studio some of objectives in 2008 so
it's just two years and if you look at
your website you describe yourselves as
kind of like ideas you know interested
in ideas which since we are university
that should moralize work but i think
it's sort of interesting to sort of as
it would take the measure of an office
after just two years likes a very very
short time given that even the shortest
of projects in architecture is generally
longer than two years so actually it
sort of impossible to be doing the
lecture and i'm interested in that sort
of the way in which this lecture is sort
of premature and and and and and yet on
the other hand of course you both have
very long histories and a lot of
experience and so actually you are
yourselves responsible for many
completed buildings of the highest
quality but then you started this new
venture which puts you back so anyways
you have this very interesting situation
of having been involved in some of the
most beautiful and complex buildings in
the world and now you find yourself like
rebooting and even that's official like
so for example in 2010 just passed you
guys did the ps1 young young architects
program with the pole dance and so on so
you're officially young artists right
and if in just in case nobody understood
the point then you win the aia new york
young practices award so you're not only
a young practice but you're officially a
young practice but also an award-winning
young practice which means you're you
could get the award cause you're like
younger than the other young practices
like you're the really young ones and
there's a bit of a risk here because
it's sort of suggests that maybe young
practices have ideas and all practices
have a reality right and so if you could
become real you stop talking about ideas
and i think it's certainly interesting
that some of the architects that
interest us a lot who continue to be
successful continue to be ideas people
even though officially they could give
up with ideas
talking about contract so my little
point here is that it's not so simple
really if officially if you look at the
kind of projects you're doing they
involve exactly the kind of experimental
zone so characteristic not only of young
architects but i would say of the youth
of the field itself like pavilions
installations exhibitions magazine
teaching all of these laboratory our
conditions which inc incubate the most
interesting thoughts and sometimes
produce buildings and sometimes don't
but remain in a way the threshold in
which act the architectural discipline
mainly operates or to set another way
around even even if you did a great
building if any athlete is great
building if it didn't resonate in that
space of magazines publications
exhibition actually would have no value
so it's not only the place in which we
incubate ideas that can't be built but
even if we do build they have to come
back into that zone so i think actually
the so-called young architects become
very interesting because they are the
caretakers of a of a zone of the
discourse and just to show how I think
it's not so simple you guys did the
house for Iran and Jane trimmer over and
that same it seems to me a super
interesting Commission so this means the
so-called super young offers does this
commission for a person who's not so
young actually precisely not young but
it's a very very experienced and famous
designer and is the son of one of the
great architectural you know chimney of
one of the great designers and thinkers
so somehow the youth thing in the and
the age thing all sort of come together
and I noticed in the interview you did
with with Jimmy if he says this
beautiful thing that his father's great
acting but he didn't want to be an actor
because it takes us take so long to do
things i takes forever so you became
more like a graphic designer there you
find yourself and then you're in the
office of sejima with sam c'mere so so
that so basically the so called youth
thing
I'm not a believer in it I mean actually
you're not young in almost any other
field you should be retiring right and
if so so I just you know just saying
that like so yes again you know yes
young offers but actually yeah it takes
Arctic's a long time to learn how to
begin it would seem and and the best
architects once they've mastered the art
of being young they do really well so I
think the way the way things operate an
architecture it's not like you're young
and then you get old you're actually old
then you go to architecture school we
teach you how to be young and then you
try to perfect the art of being young
and so I sort of see you guys right at
the epicenter of our field anyway it's a
big responsibility but they are also two
of the nicest people in the universe and
absolutely fabulous teachers so we're
really really lucky that you're teaching
with us welcome back second thank you
were gonna start
what do we turn off the light again I
think we're actually very young not to
say but also as the age of the office
because the for me or the name it's also
kind of this network of people and the
dynamic and connection office together
and indeed the identity of solid object
at night and regulatory office started
two and half years ago and that the only
reason I think we are here tonight I was
largely to moderate group of people who
had been working with us and a great
supporter of our ideas and have given us
some people have given given us chance
to work with this simple math vector and
I think to build up this group of people
it takes a life
and we only second year age of that we
are very young office and so the
sediments the sedimentation is
accumulated throughout this two and half
years which should we attract tonight in
the form of lecture in a way on attempt
to tell a cohesive story but we're
probably the first one to admit that is
our own story for our own version
emporia died
version of the story so but nevertheless
we try the title you see here to be
determined loosely ties together the six
project that we're going to present
tonight with a theme that's to post the
first first of all it refers to the
social in the natural construction of
this world that we're living which can
be said to be something to be
experienced as something irrational
indeterminate multi-layered and the
constant influx influx and sometimes
even volatile it is not possible to
escape the way in which that the
feelings of fantasies and and anxieties
and predators the prejudice and fears
and all this other unstable feelings
that woven their way into these times
that we're living so and secondly
supposedly that we can free ourselves
from this fascination to the stable the
monument and explicit we can start to
maybe grasp the elastic environments
that we're living
we in a way we're very doubtful of the
fast-tracking modernity that we all
learn in the school can offer us a
resolution and we contemplate in the
Wonder ever since elastic maybe which
are just float in this list of unstable
but determinate determined intentions so
one of the first practical concerns of
this new ecology that I refer to is you
know our own relationship with
surroundings our surroundings and I
think with modernity it granted us with
the law of nature which we found the
stable structure and uniformity however
increasingly in the recent history we
have come to understand that this
uniformity to try derives from the
projection of our own desires which is
to a large extent have become richer and
more device diverse diverse we are
subject where subjects that's
responsible for the construction of this
grid of structure that has become very
unstable and sometimes waste and on the
skills that are barely touching the
ground beneath us so with this kind of
salt we enter the competition for the
ps1 and moma young architects program of
2010 and moma is a very modern
institution
with its association comes with the
Bauhaus tradition this is the ostrich
this is oscar schmidt numbers
choreography keys or the poor dance
which we wanted to pay tribute to in our
proposal to this competition but also we
attempt to this stabilize it in our
proposal so in the courtyard of ps1 we
played out ad fiberglass poles on a
elastic grid that's constructed by Tom G
ports and awaiting this environment we
inserted activators such as hammocks and
ladders and misters and then this post
are connected to the ground with only
the pin connection allowing them to be
dynamically moving within the system
so and the witness various activators as
we called the waned the pressure of the
water and the people play that the
system becomes something that the
subject engages with and with this
structure we hoped that the people would
rain gauge was the physical world and
find faithfulness with aiding their
interaction and another important thing
was really the desire to create an
inferior so very much a space if you
enter rather than a null ket so the
sensorial spatial rather than the form
ribbon architectural project or
something to do the trying to experiment
so another component of this project is
that within in the small courtyard next
to the naked main space as the
environment of the immersive and
interactive part of the installation
which the eight post in this small
courtyard are have the accelerometer
which is o have the accelerometers which
is the devices that detects the motions
of objects and they have these
accelerometers embedded ingham that also
a sound engineer programmed education
that would trance trans form the data of
motion that's detected into a tone
music or tone sound that will be can be
played in the space with speakers and so
and also some application designers have
gathered this data and put them into the
iphone application that each polls can
be claimed on your mobile phones and the
zoo clicking through them you can
manipulate the effect of each of these
polls the sound they make and together
neighborhood
labor
so the idea is that everyone who can get
on this application would be able to
claim a poll virtually and change the
volume of the pole and you can also
shake it and manipulate sound of the
pole now with this application we
attempted to basically realign the
physical and the virtual and maybe with
this combination to to see if they're
sending some similarities within two
orders maybe they are one of the same
thing the idea indeed do anything in a
way PS one asks us to also react to this
big blessing of sustainability with
everybody every architectural project
knowledge to answer to and so our
thinking was also maybe if we can find a
way that people get more they're
stronger sensibility towards the
physical or what has happened what has
happened with our relation to the
physical
is there a way that we can come up with
the device of the connects us to the
disco as everybody has escaped say in
the virtual space and so by actually
using the playfulness the virtual I'm
seeing if we could be instill that into
the physical we wanted to basically
bring people's attention back to the
physical environment but by providing a
hybrid so the hybrid of the virtual and
physical you know refer to the American
student environment so this is written
since the Flickr page where people who
directly with their iPhone upload
pictures that they would take in the
Indus base and what we just fast I think
before was this is you can make drawings
with these poles as well so these are
sounds generated drawings that come from
these poles with these accelerometers in
them so there's drawing Pope tests that
could be uploaded onto this website that
we organized here to buy for and Arab
yeah so I think is one of the other
point that's worth noting is that to our
great pleased that this installation
to which many collaborators and come to
us
integrate to their own project
so Eric with the Sun
and also the national champion pole
dancers came to us and wanted to do
their own projects
surprising as a very good result
precisely
holding up our project but also project
with the open platform and this video
I'm going to show you now
oh can also out of voluntary
collaborator
the
alright the next project so apart from
doing trying to enter young architects
competitions we do other competitions
this is actually a young architects
competition as well this was in athens
greece a competition and pulled up to 35
so we could still and join that for a
young developer the was also under 35
who had this ambition or has this
ambition for an area in downtown Athens
Greece to through student housing
basically we generate this neighborhood
this neighborhood is and it's called
Martinez and Jeremy cause it's two
streets that define this area and this
shows the site of the of the competition
actually the exact site of this this
entry was here it was an open
competition about I think 250 people
that entered and we entered as well what
the neighborhood is indeed a
neighborhood in transition it is a
working-class neighborhood very dense on
the ground very sort of typical loud
streets and then a yards in the back
that are not really necessarily used and
somewhere there's sort of a big
disconnect between what is happening in
the industry and what is happening in
the back and through a simple operation
and something that was possible within
the local code we actually shifted the
bulk of the the mass on this site it
created an opportunity to make a new
typology if you would like especially
this being
a typology for young pretty young for
for college students it's a time in your
life when you're still willing to
rethink maybe how to live how to live in
the city you have to live with one
another and by this mark this small sort
of simple shift you also create equality
for all the units that happened in there
so it's a very democratic move which
seems quite appropriate for the location
of the competition the the what it also
does is it really opens up the street
into the yard so it opens it sort of
opens up the block and brings that
public in and it allows basically this
is all to become the buffer between the
units and the end the street itself it
does give you obviously very narrow and
slim section of a building four and a
half meter of building a four-and-a-half
litre of yard and so we designed it very
very precise almost like a like a
Japanese capsule hotel and we did want
to give all the students their private
unit not some sort of large collective
dorm style living everybody have their
own unit that we we organized it sort of
in zones from super personal and closed
gradually to more open and more public
and I think this the age for which this
typology and building is is exactly
probably you guys but it's where you
jump from sort of very intimate and
concentrated modes to very open and
exuberant and so this we try to pack
these different modes into a very small
confined section so here you see almost
like a fun further keeping the style
efficiency in the in the room where you
study the cooking is in sleep and then
this view out to this yard this yard is
actually a vertical yard so you see all
these lives
sort of happening within the was in his
elevation we varied the section to
generate some variety also in the spaces
ultimately and 16 or well there was a
puzzle to try to get in as many units as
possible between 16 and 18 and this
shared terraces as a way to move up in
the building and getting to your room is
also passing somebody in front of their
window so the way to stimulate social
exchange as well in this yard that can
be occupied by students and the in a way
very clean and simple abstract facade as
within this chaotic neighborhood and
part of the competition was not only to
come up with an answer or one type but
actually look at the neighborhood as a
whole and think of this as a sort of a
viral typology that could start taking
over the entire neighborhood and so we
were actually one of the finalists we
didn't win the competition that we were
with the last five and we could further
develop the scheme and especially our
this strategy of opening up the block
and gradually through this intervention
if you would do this on all sites the
whole urban fabric would actually start
to change and rather than having as hard
a division between streets and inner
court you get much more porous and
diffused urban fabric so this was our
argument also for as a strategy to take
over this entire loan what was
interesting so that we indeed did not we
were selected for the final project the
next day indeed this young developer
called us and said we like that strategy
and this strategy works very well on
other lots that we have so the next day
we started to work on a much larger more
from the other side of the street right
here and that is something that is in
development now obviously also apart
from the US Greece is also suffering
somewhat from financial constraints so
at this moment we are and i will show
you where we where we are what was
interesting here so this is the other
side of the street this is literally
sort of facing the site where we did the
competition is it this site is much
deeper actually and it also allowed us
to think of more variety and typology
there was a shift towards young families
the desire for a coffee shop and a cafe
so the idea actually that these
different buildings as it takes over the
neighborhood have different amenities
that can be shared between all the units
the complication here is also we had to
include three stories of parking so this
became actually very intricate puzzle
and with open Utley how many units like
be honest how many enlisted we have the
honors and Elios from our officer also
here they've worked very hard on this
project I think we ended up with about
around 50 units and this project at this
moment is developed up to schematic
design but we actually continue to sort
of push it not just to keep it alive but
also because it it is an exploration for
us of how you can think about the city
so this is an exhibition we had in the
at studio x there where we actually
assumed that we had taken over the
entire neighborhood with this with this
typology a sort of see how yeah Alex in
out develop third project which keeps us
in Asia is something we're working on
right now and in Seoul this is downtown
so or basically the North it used to be
the old town it's a view from a mountain
towards the castle the main castle you
know I'm sure there's people here from
Seoul and they probably recognize that
this is I think it's what some job done
place maybe somebody can correct me room
if they know it better but it's
basically the old downtown area where
there's a lot of old courtyard homes and
we the this is the idea behind this
project is driven by two things one is
to the very local and specific any other
game and this is maybe more our sort of
internal idea and research or the
discussion that we had with in the
office but as Mark said we are here to
speak about ideas as well not justify
solutions and at some point A student
presented her work and she said well you
know this can be sort of kind of well
whatever and I initially thought it was
quite lame sort of description of the
project but then realized that maybe
everything these days can be sort of
kind of whatever because in the past
maybe we made buildings to do something
but this one google of these stuff
online or
virtual realm so almost everything we
make can maybe be sort of kind of
whatever and so we started to think how
what does that look like if you actually
have to design that or and so we got
interested in thinking about sort of
deliberate ambivalence and this idea of
something that is ambivalence or
something you can't grasp actually
becomes maybe more desirable rather than
something that is very explicit and very
easy to understand so somewhere the
mystique of something that you can't
grasp something that is it has this
undefined or undetermined quality is
maybe something that we can desire this
yeah this is not something we shared
with our client our client is Miss Lee
she has a gallery a large gallery cook
gallery in in this neighborhood and you
see on the left side and so the original
courtyard style homes in at the back you
see the evil gallery sort of you know
moving into this neighborhood ms lee has
been quite successful in doing that this
are her first two buildings Gucci
gallery one which he started about i
think twenty years ago twenty-five years
ago and her second building and cooked
cheer too and so those two were built
and when they came to us they had sort
of infiltrated in his neighborhood you
see here these all to the holdouts of
other homes but his neighborhood is
beginning to becoming very popular it's
a very nice walkable area where you know
people come in weekends young couples to
eat there puffing creme and other drink
fancy coffees and we so we were asked to
look at
third building over the which is here
the first to exist and at this moment
actually an hour work on this is
expanding to redesign the first building
in the second building we're making
adjustments there but initially we were
asked to only think about this third
building everybody else on this fourth
building NASA visit of them maybe in a
way relates to Greece in the sense that
it becomes the porous semi-public piece
of of city and well let's let's talk
about this third building so the idea of
this hard simple light box moving into
this dense and fluid and historic fabric
we well it's one of the multiple
galleries and so soul is getting a
little bit nervous about these larger
boxes moving moving in but still the
requirements especially this one they
wanted light and large project space 15
meters by 10 meters 7 meters high one
big space in which they can have large
installations so we provided them with
the box and we very in very
straightforward diagrammatic way pushed
out the circulation and the entrances so
you keep the pure and say minimalist
white box and very simple entrance
elevator corridor down stairs and stair
up are pushed out the large basement
there is a lecture hall downstairs and
where they will have presentations for
here collectors and a second basement
with the storage and parking so that was
the it's pretty much didn't the scope
they hear the simple white
artspace with the sky lights all around
daylight is important and then we have
to think how do we how do we bring this
white box into the entities urban fabric
and so this idea say deliberate
ambiguity and the idea of making
something that is that maybe because of
the fact the fact that it is not a hard
edge but actually a sort of a softer and
a diffuser object then maybe that could
be so the negotiator between this
historic fabric and underwater the hard
edge this is a painting actually off the
site and the whole degree in painting
it's true and this is the site and there
is actually a river and that is where
the where the building is now and we're
actually feeling it while building our
foundations there's a lot of water in
the ground this is so within an say
traditional korean you know painting is
also dislike the idea of a Laird as a
diffused pneus of fogginess and actually
then we found one contemporary
photographer that they represented also
as the same sort of say a cloud like a
quality to their and to their work and
we thought what if we have we take this
diagram and we actually sort of shrink
wrap it in in a layer of diffusion in a
way and it sounded all great and we made
a model and and it's we indeed literally
a shrink-wrapped and this diagram into
this reflective sort of armor and we
presented it and Leslie said that's
great make it we first have to get some
approval from the historic committee so
we and this is the file we had
especially this diagram i think is quite
and strong in showing how well it fits
within the neighborhood and so we got an
approval then the question is of course
great but what is it and we had to think
especially because this is a double
curvature it's called
but at the same time it needs to be
exterior what so it needs to be strong
so what is a strong which you know what
is durable outside and can take on a
double curvature the chainmail mesh is
very simple a thing used well for people
that love the past it's also used or
love the past it's all they used for
belly dancing attire end for the butcher
gloves and it's only made actually on
the on the scale of the body so I'm
quite small scale I think the biggest
this is a machine-made biggest the
diameter is 13 millimeters so it's a
little more than a centimeter it's but
you can buy from a and it's a
manufacturer um this is too small
obviously for building so we started the
test first by just laser cutting and
different dimensions in our office to
see what is the right size and at the
same time we started to see that this
material actually has so what gives it
these elastic qualities we started to
play with how it works geometrically we
got a sample and we started to see how
sort of it behaves and we they're sort
of the directionality and we found out
that there is a way in which indeed
listening and stretches which allows for
it to take on the double curvature so
we've mapped the entire perimeter of the
building and so we're sort of its
maximum expansion that it's it's it's
title is obviously the roof would be one
hundred percent and then you can stretch
it along the rest circle area of the
building and by then we realize okay if
we're really going to do this we have to
get an engineer on board and we actually
we have to figure this out because we
have to
obviously this thing doesn't exist and
how do you come up with well it needed
to get approvals and be survive
earthquakes and etc so we teamed up with
front the facade engineers we asked them
if they want to help us with this and
they said yes we're going to do a we're
going to work together on if we're going
to do a digital trajectory and just the
physical trajectory so we started to do
some really super simple and fearful
testing by the seeing how the forces
behave because there's actually very
little knowledge about this material
available and we started to see sort of
initial patterns of stress and how they
behave this model became more complex to
a level where we almost have every ring
model and we build a large model model
in our offices one to ten scale model
and I with the reins to actually see how
it would behave in its physical
proportion so it's really both i think
that are important both the physical and
the digital and the need to work but
together and starts to and well any way
through that these things can work to
mix them by then we knew quite a bit
about this material and we actually also
have to think of how to install it and
then and we together with drug decided
why don't we just actually just
fabricate the thing ourselves and
deliver it and probably you know we're
going to be installing it as well
because you know there's it's in these
are all things aspects you need to think
through so where do you go and get this
you go to alibaba.com and
people were not familiar with
alibaba.com sudden match.com between
people that make things and people that
need things and so once we put in an
inquiry at alibaba.com with drainage we
got a ton of factories in China actually
through skype pretty much approaching
us-1 skype name was appropriately called
ring and so she we are we started to
chat with one of these people and they
we started work with them when they
actually provided us a large mocha or
large sample this is a 8 feet by 6 feet
or something and it was very promising a
skype relationship we started to develop
and at some point same as the people you
meet at match.com you have to see each
other in real life and so we decided to
go to China not this was about well over
half a year ago to UM ping'an dumping is
six hours west of Beijing and in a town
where after quite a sort of intense car
ride we ended up in this town and it was
pretty rough town you can buy dogs and
we ended up in this very small courtyard
I would say as big as the stage here and
there was our sample and we we looked
around this woman had just eaten her
food and this is a little room off of
this courtyard and all the way in the
back there's one machine and we're even
behind that machine was one boy and this
boy was their hand police
uh rings together so we have guaranteed
to our client that we would be able to
deliver this mesh and this was the
moment sort of a realization of what we
had discussed the man here on the left
also realized that when we told him that
the road actually four hundred thousand
dreams that it would probably take him
more than ten years to put the facade
together this is an Mike yeah actually
Jing who is from China also acknowledged
she had never been so deep into China so
this was a very deep China for the
Chinese micra from front they're also
thinking gee what did I what did I
promise what we did is we took this
sample and we actually went to another
company because smartly Jing had seen
that most of the skype reactions
actually all came from this town own
thing and a more aggressive a company
they they took the sample I said we can
do this and within 24 hours we found a
number of companies of Calypso Mike was
happy again and we well now at this
moment we actually we just commissioned
one of these companies that the one with
the tiger is actually making the
Internationale so we could happily start
digging and this was just two weeks ago
and they finished all the pouring of the
concrete the foundation and the project
should be done in
in November this project and then we're
going to continue to work on these other
projects on that site yeah you're going
to do yeah so this next project is also
me it's also in Asia it's a 400 square
meter exhibition space that's erected in
a myth center of daydream this is a new
knee felt center that's mimicking the
Rockefeller Center development and so in
this place a culture festival called get
louder that's led by the culture
computer Oh Ling and our contributor
Eric Chen and they approached us two
months before the opening of the
festival and asked us maybe
exhibition and pavilion space for all
the screening and lecturing programs to
take place during the festival and we
said no because we never say no was that
yes this time too so two days later we
got a project schedule which indicated
that we need to deliver their
construction documents in the following
week so but we remained optimistic and
proposed something very quick to them
along the same similar thoughts that we
had as a stable structure that we
experimented in ps1 at that moment so
our proposal was this vertical
structures that's connected only on one
and rigidly and on the other and
gathered with pension ring and the
spring would be held down by I
adjustable weights and so by
manipulating way so you would get a
different curvature of that vertical
member therefore the shifting
transforming form of the pavilion
constructor itself and it should keep
the ring and Psalm out we would
guitars on the upper portion of the
pavilion and this topic and just be
changed from the one location to the
other because the festival was supposed
to take place in Beijing Shanghai and
Guangzhou so they liked that idea very
much but they said in Beijing would have
very strong wind so we need to the in
stable structure is not going to work
sped away well approximate your
engineering solution with our engineer
and this is the our approximation and
this is the detail thank you very much
and before we know it was erected so and
it was so and the next question they had
was okay about this skirt and we liked
it very much but we need also for the
same wind reason we need a little bit
more substantial skirt so this time we
learned our lesson immediately proposed
solution that would be
you know within two days we proposed a
solution that would just hand this on
stainless steel panels to the horizontal
members that spends on this vertical
members and they would be connected only
loosely at the top so when the Wayne
becomes the supposedly very strong wind
of Beijing comes and would create this
ripple effect I'm asking out the window
I mean of the building so they said oh
that sounds like a great idea the only
thing is that the standard still it's
too expensive if we change them to
plastic and make them thicker they
should be achieved exactly the same
effect and that we found the list colors
that's available on the market we think
the three colors matches to your
standard steel specifications but please
confirm so we pondered for a few hours
and concluded that if the kind of
subtlety that we intended to achieve
with the stainless steel panels cannot
be achieved then maybe you know we
should go for alien Liz so we said let's
go with chocolate pink because the
shocking pink has luckily quite a few
variations with family and because we
thought a subtlety and in
aenean is it sort of the two ends of the
same scale of the two ends of the
sliding scale of differentiations so was
this you know three shocking pink
variations we sort of got both so by
this time one hour on the ground local
staff told us that our custom detail for
the hinge was replaced by tie wrap we
were not so surprised and we were not so
disappointed either I think we were
actually quite pleased that by this
point that that this tag of war
relationship with the clients and the
contractors there and also the kind of
the situation that no one can do
anything about is fascinating to us it's
a new relationship that it's a new
relationship that's kind of constantly
shifting and transforming and and maybe
in this situation everyone is a winner
and no one is
the opening and they said why he went
even walk up because we already built so
with this invitation I flew to Beijing
and they're looking at this shocking
pink building in front of me and I was
wondering if we are the author of this
design however just go back to my point
earlier that I think it's precisely from
this kind of hybridized dynamic that mr.
apologies and mutant materials are
formed and there's something interesting
in that that the architects will not be
the person that holds irons them but
rather we are the people who can
negotiate between keep different peoples
and different ideas and different places
and maybe we can be the interface
between software links
jingus new energy there's a short video
of the effect of the sting
I never saw the thing actually because
but so fast today had a chance to to go
there but it mostly so the video is same
the most information story maybe I can
clarify why we're going to show now a
tumor project one is a competition entry
we just did and we're showing this I
think more because of the way we did the
projects are sorted from a process
standpoint and we worked together with
Arab acoustical engineers with whom we
had developed a relationship through ps1
and so this is a competition in poland
in Warshaw for a symphony hall 1500
people symphony hall and what is
interesting in the competition brief is
that the architectural brief was like
three pages in the acoustical briefs
pretty much 50 pages and so the jury was
also mostly acousticians and it gave us
well it was very interesting is that it
immediate first of all it means that as
a young and small office it actually
allows you to participate in these
things because it sort of the weight
within such a project can be shared the
the sort of the load the workload and
also the would say the the ideas load
that needs to be put into it and it's
also really interesting to see how
indeed maybe the architectural practices
is changing and much more collaborative
spirit and so that's one reason to to
show it at the same time I think what is
interesting is the way we're trying to
develop a design method it gives options
open towards the end let me first
explain a little bit about the project
itself this is the token Google Earth
picture for when you can't go on a site
visit but this is in the east of Poland
there in the entry in Warsaw the less
developed part the historical part is on
the west side and right here you see
park and this olds veterinary Institute
which was to be the site for this
competition the veterinary Institute had
been there for a very long time and
solicit of an enclaves within the city
beautiful but inaccessible the the idea
was to move this symphony hall within
this enclaves and also bring in
rehearsal halls and educational parts
within a number of old buildings that
were on the site beautiful as a lush
area within the city and so and and to
add this large concert hall and these
buildings they have they certainly had a
certain capacity but the 1500 seed
concert was quite a large hall to land
within this site the historic buildings
were also already used for some local
music school and so I will briefly
explain the way we came up with the form
which have to do in a way with how do
you deal with on the one had this very
Bridget access of the existing buildings
in this classical central symmetrical
access at the same time the ambition to
come up with a form that opens up the
sites to a larger audience and actually
reaches out to an audience beyond the
site itself so we kept the axis we kept
the project on access but actually
through its form we try to generate a
space that exists beyond
site and we were able to get all the set
every program and facilities into the
old buildings and could make the concert
hall itself a sort of an individual room
in the back of the site which you see
over here the form and in a way opens up
towards the two words the city allows
daylight into the space also into the
concert hall itself which is actually a
quite exciting thing and also anyway
tries to respect the space of the the
old buildings around it and so here you
see and it was also it was a way a
struggle to see how big such space or
such hole needs to lead student and be
so this is the overall organization what
I and its relation to the park and sort
of the way we opened it up by making the
entire perimeter permeable and then the
the hole itself is actually quite
straightforward in a sense that you have
the Conn circle which needs to be
enclosed acoustically sealed space and
then you have the lobbies to fly A's and
that can happen between this interior
skin and as exterior skin and then
there's a much rehearsal post orchestra
rehearsal hall underneath which can be
visible from the from the lobby and then
there's a second movie where people with
tickets go and then they sort of move up
two staircases in between this shell
actually between the inner wall of the
whole of the outer wall of the of the
form here you see the lobby and the
underbelly of the of the
up and then for the hole itself it was
very interesting well there's basically
two psychologists concert halls one is
the shoe box which is sort of a deep
classic I'm Saddam circa or the y ella
and music hall and then there is this
since obviously chahoon the much more
dramatic and currently desirable
vineyard setting also the Disney Hall by
Gary and it uses this and actually as I
sort of a shift from listening to seeing
people like more dramatic holes where
the sound is actually less great than
the straight box where the acoustics are
good but maybe you can't show your new
mink coat so we deposit of a drive for
than this vineyard type setting and we
and it means that there's a news of
architectural project within the design
of that of the way people are organized
within that space and so the vineyard is
a very dramatic visual the rich type and
so we were we went in search for an
image that could that we could use in a
way to work two words or basically as a
sort of inspiration this is a Cheshire
drawing obviously the mathematician who
made complicated and geometric drawings
and this became sort of a thing to chase
with in this design and what was nice is
that so here really the dialogue between
Arab and us was very it was a very
collaborative and actually back and
forth type of method so we had to come
up with it with a way of working in
which we could refine at the acoustics
at the same time get this architectural
idea in there and the idea of this say
asurion comb straight was post the idea
of making to the scaffold like a network
that would sit loose as a as an
individual structure within this
acoustical the shell so you have an
acoustic shell and then within that this
stuff is really open
and lace like more like mesh likes of
independent structure where people would
sit and it would allow for daylight even
to come in behind the seats and people
to circulate behind the seat so we
developed this concept which is the
variable volume where the acoustics of
the hall can actually dramatically
change depending on the volume that is
made available so this inner seating
structure could be closed off and such
that the volume of the hall could be
closed which gives you a different
reverberation time and then the entire
space can open up for larger orchestras
and so at the other part list of the
acoustical Paul where the the sights of
the walls behind the seeding reflect the
sound back so these were given by arup
and we worked with them very very near
we also didn't copy the movie this is
also a movie which shows basically a
parametric model that we came up with
which allows which allowed us to
continuously refine the shape of the
room and change it while sticking to the
parameters that were Kevin and by arup
and so actually we only have to fix the
room and so the last minute but at the
same time could guarantee its acoustical
performance this is a physical model
that of that lattice structure that will
be inserted in the acoustical shell and
hear some imagery that will look
and a view at night this one we also
didn't win and we will continue to do
more competitions until we win one now
Jing is going to show our first project
yes this is our first project tells us
the last project of tonight this is the
project that the mark referred to in the
introduction in many ways it was the
first was the perfect first project
because it made us to think some of the
most fundamental issues within
architected discipline it is the you
know single family were more like for
the older couple on holiday house cited
on the Hudson along the hudson valley in
new york state you're in garrison and so
the project is a it's a week weekend
house and it's for this modernist
graphic designer items in Maya who's
also portrayed in this picture and
that's him and this are some of the
project that has done in his life so he
was the if you not familiar with him
basically he cleaned up all the mess of
the pre-modern great corporate logos and
fonts in America and worked in continue
to work in this modernist tradition to
this day and so for us to work with him
it was an interesting dialogue between
our two between him and us as a
different generations and we proposed to
challenge this conventional men looking
over nature trope as often done in a
modernist fashion and so do wait kind of
a by dissolving and distributing the
mass of mass of the buildings into a
loose gathering of the solid and the
boys into the site we create a house
that's equally open in all directions
and welcomes nature in the common
programs and the living room dialing
room library bedrooms and bathrooms are
they all have each have their individual
volumes and there
all connected and separated from each
other by this enclosed courtyard in the
middle there are two of them ones here
and ones here and so the path is this
kind of configuration allow passive
cooling to go through the building which
and also we had trees and we try to not
cut the magnificent trees around an
insight and also have to in the
courtyard and used that as shading to
avoid to eliminated active cooling
systems will be playing the film that
mark referred to earlier which will talk
about the design great detail so I'm not
going to explain it too much but just to
walk you through the space this is a
library which is one of the solid volume
and this is the living room that's
between adjacent to the library and
that's in the glass volume sort of the
void that that I mentioned earlier this
is the living room looking at the pub
the other side this is the bathroom and
that's also a void which is a glass
volume so this can only be done if you
have a lot of force around you and so
this is a
the collection of solid and void and
inviting the nature in so unfortunately
this is a project that did not was
cancelled right after the CD was
completed and yea even after we got the
building permit but unfortunately we
were able to capture some parts of the
story with this short interview
I missed the tower don't you I do the
greater exaggeration of the heights I
think was kind of important thing I
think essentially the brief is the
flexibility of having guests and M
family from time to time but basically
it's the two of us where I can make a
mess and where Jane can make a mess
because I like to do my own artwork and
make collages and even my studio doesn't
require a lot of space because I don't
do large painting so I'm not chipping
away at big stones with hammers and it
but it's again part of the plan of the
house is to have what months would be
called studio and work place for Jane
separated from mine so that we're not in
fury with each other every minute and
where we found this site it i would say
it looked out if one could see through
the trees in all directions probably
more than 300 degrees out of 360 it was
geologically very dramatic in the sense
of its rocks hills came up in very quick
succession so it's very
three-dimensional territory if this is a
house I think that what I could say they
grew out of the client and the and the
site and the problem because they're two
spaces which
completely open to the sky so that that
means another kind of light and but if
you're in one of the other you're
looking through the real space real in
the sense of dirt and sky to the other
space so that there's a sense of
enlargement of what you do have because
of this mixture of indoor/outdoor open
closed night mix exactly and that's very
important and most houses don't work
like that no and most part in the houses
you go from one room to another they all
you can do is see back through the
doorway to what you just left but not a
sense of space usually we're talking
about moving Iraq that the only way
you'd get it there would be before the
house and the walls go up otherwise it
would weigh too much I mean five tons of
over 10,000 pound Boulder and big as
this table and that high you know that's
a real stone it's a matter of bringing
the inside outside even more I noticed
though that you don't have it in the
rather be related but it said I think
you shouldn't put it in the model too
because I think it's kind of it we have
one is Mark Hall it is that a rock in
there yes does that I think it makes a
difference having been brought up in in
in a very modern contemporary world with
with it in every way with not only your
father a brother a son who are
architects only reason I'm not and I
could take this because I don't have the
patience to wait for things to happen on
graphic design I do hundred times more
jobs and ninety-five percent of mine had
done my father was born in the Caucasus
and was there the land that his family
had was breeding and raising horses and
a thousand thousands of acres and was an
incredible long thing but they when they
discovered oil on their lands which
didn't really affect what they did that
much but it made them rich as Croesus
but in 1917 he went from being a rich
young man to pennis Bolsheviks took away
everything he didn't have any more than
the clothes on his back more or less
nothing he was on his own from 17 years
of age arm that was that was that so he
was as he always said he was saved by
having everything taken away because
otherwise he move you know and be in
pantaloons you know slobby pain in the
ass but so he became an architect and
educator in great universities Harvard
Yale mrt is to design it was very
important the teacher to an awful lot of
architects he never studied architecture
in his life in every winters architect I
don't school about the ten minutes he
decided to be an architect period and
did it the idea of the problems of
architecture was something that I always
had a sort of instinctive fear about
that because so many things start and
don't get done
for sometimes for good reason sometimes
for bad reasons and not as well off as I
would hope to be a after working hard
for 50 60 years because otherwise i'd be
glad to build it and make it bigger i
think if you were looking at you know
but i realized that not only that but in
my age my agent was going to go down
even if i survive that guaranteed it's
not guaranteed that i'll survive it off
and guarantee that if I do that I won't
be Richard guaranteed not possible well
this is a nice site but which I still
own and somebody will build a house
maybe they're bogus on I think this is
still too personal arriving here it's
also it's as you said the architecture
architecture is very different from
gothic design you have to it doesn't
always happen yeah but it is to them
because i think it you know if ever and
just could afford it it could been
expanded and and i would love to have it
or not just because it's
we didn't want to lead you in such a sad
movie this is the end of our lecture
thank you
jeremias archives while you were doing
research for that price no we did not
but no we did not know we spoke a lot
with with Ivan himself of course we cut
at one part of the video which you can
find on our site or elsewhere I mean it
basically to be reduced it further and
further down but at some point he speaks
about his relationship to Boyer and the
impact Brewer homes had on him he says
that he used to pick Brewers apples so
the there was a more of a sort of a
brewer reference there then then looking
at his his father yeah
I hope